[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
this is the Chromebook pixel and it's my
unboxing and first impressions now
before you guys go all whoa mkbhd you
must be nuts for paying $1,300 for a web
browser take a second go ahead and check
out my Chromebook pixel explaining video
it opens in a new tab it's the first
link below the like button on this video
and that'll take you to my first
impressions and thoughts on this machine
but now I have it here in person to
check it out for myself and hopefully
I'll be able to give you guys enough
information from my experience with it
to help you decide what you think of the
pixel either way let's get into this
full retail unboxing since I wasn't one
of the cool kids to get a loaner from
Google right off the bat when you open
the box you're presented with the
Chromebook itself super nice and I also
like this packaging but we'll put that
to the side for a second next you
actually get a card with some help so
there's a site dedicated to Chromebook
pixel customer support so that's cool
then of course below that is the charger
it's very reminiscent of the Asus
Zenbook and MacBook chargers that plug
directly into the wall so it's a pretty
small brick and it does say Chrome on it
which is a nice touch then again you
also get the larger cable so if you want
to plug it into the wall further away
from you that is totally cool too and
then you get your safety and warranty
information as well and that's it the
unboxing is done so taking a closer look
at the laptop it is immediately apparent
as soon as you pick it up and hold the
thing that it is built well it is a
completely unibody design and it's a
really nice clean feel no obtrusive
logos or anything protruding anywhere in
fact it's one of the most minimalist
understated designs you could say
handsome designs of any laptop I've ever
seen including the original cr-48
Chromebook this port layout is also as
we have expected pretty basic on the
left side there's power a mini display
port two USB 2.0 ports and an audio port
and on the right side is just an SD card
reader so although this is all nice and
pretty basic I would have liked to see
more video out options like some HDMI
action thrown in there but that's
alright all this looking around the
device also really gets you to look at
two things one how thin it really is on
to how much attention to detail went
into this design it's a really handsome
notebook it's nice and clean
unibody feel like I said everything from
the hinge to the logo placement if you
in the right place and I love that and
then you open it up for the first time
and Chrome OS boots and the display
turns on and then you realize why this
thing is premium that is a 2560 by 1713
inch display and it has a pixel density
of 239 PPI this is the sharpest display
we've ever seen in a laptop and don't
worry yes I will go more into the detail
with that in the full review video but
basically the display is awesome in
every way I've watched the Timescape 4k
demo video that comes pre-loaded on it
just for kicks and you can see
everything every little detail it really
does show up as being a little bit
glossy though so you'll have to angle it
properly to get rid of the lights but
then again it is a touchscreen too so
there is some fun thrown into there I
don't know it's just an awesome package
centered around that nice display which
is where the Chromebook pixel gets its
name so the hardware is pretty much at
first glance definitely awesome and
playing around with Chrome OS version 25
is also fun too now most of us are
already familiar with Chrome most of us
in fact are probably watching this video
in chrome right now but Chrome OS has a
lot of additions and tweaks to it that
make it seem like way more than just a
browser first of all all the multi
window support is nice the search
functionality all the keys that are
integrated with it and the inevitable
upcoming additions like Google now and
notifications etc all these things
hopefully will come together to make
this feel like a more complete operating
system experience plus the touch screens
so that really gives you sort of a new
experience with Google Chrome now it's
difficult to live completely in the
cloud for some people and I understand
that but the purpose of this video right
here the reason this video is on YouTube
is to ask you guys what do you want to
see in the Chromebook pixel full review
the comments section below is wide open
right below that like button and it'll
serve as a forum for all your
suggestions do you want to see
performance tests you know more info on
the screen on the operating system
gaming whatever it is let me know and I
will see it also without giving away too
much I do plan on comparing this to the
competition but that's a whole nother
mother of a topic altogether so anyway
let me know guys I'll leave you with the
Konami Easter Egg that
with that awesome badass light bar that
Google added just for kicks because it
looks cool there you go thank you for
watching and I'll talk to you guys in
the next one peace
[Music]
you
[Music]